a lot of people want to know you're one
of the most productive and brilliant
people in the history of AI what is a
productive day in the life of Andre
carpathy look like
what time do you wake up usually because
imagine
um some kind of dance between the
average productive day and a perfect
productive day so the perfect productive
day is the thing we strive
towards and the average is kind of what
it kind of converges to getting all the
mistakes and human eventualities and so
on yeah so what time do you wake up are
you morning person I'm not a morning
person I'm a night owl for sure is it
stable or not that's semi-stable like a
809 or something like that during my PhD
it was even later I used to go to sleep
usually at 3am I think uh the am hours
are are precious and very interesting
time to work because everyone is asleep
um at 8 AM or 7 A.M the east coast is
awake so there's already activity
there's already some text messages
whatever there's stuff happening you can
go on like some news website and there's
stuff happening it's distracting uh at
3am everything is totally quiet and so
you're not going to be bothered and you
have solid chunks of time to do the work
um
so I like those periods Night Owl by
default and then I think like productive
time basically
um what I like to do is you need you
need to like build some momentum on the
problem without too much distraction and
um you need to load your Ram uh your
working memory with that problem
and then you need to be obsessed with it
when you're taking shower when you're
falling asleep you need to be obsessed
with the problem and it's fully in your
memory and you're ready to wake up and
work on it right there so there's a
scale of uh is this in a scale temporal
scale of a single day or a couple of
days a week a month so I can't talk
about one day basically in isolation
because it's a whole process when I want
to get when I want to get productive in
the problem I feel like I need a span of
a few days where I can really get in on
that problem and I don't want to be
interrupted and I'm going to just uh be
completely obsessed with that problem
and that's where I do most of my good
workouts
you've done a bunch of cool like little
projects in a very short amount of time
very quickly so that that requires you
just focusing on it yeah basically I
need to load my working memory with the
problem and I need to be productive
because there's always like a huge fixed
cost to approaching any problem uh you
know like I was struggling with this for
example at Tesla because I want to work
on like small side projects but okay you
first need to figure out okay I need to
SSH into my cluster I need to bring up a
vs code editor so I can like work on
this I need to I run into some stupid
error because of some reason like you're
not at a point where you can be just
productive right away you are facing
barriers and so it's about uh really
removing all that barrier and you're
able to go into the problem and you have
the full problem loaded in your memory
and somehow avoiding distractions of all
different forms like uh news stories
emails but also distractions from other
interesting projects that you previously
worked on are currently working on and
so on you just want to really focus your
mind and I mean I can take some time off
for distractions and in between but I
think it can't be too much uh you know
most of your day is sort of like spent
on that problem and then you know I
drink coffee I have my morning routine I
look at some news uh Twitter Hacker News
Wall Street Journal Etc so he's great so
basically you wake up you have some
coffee are you trying to get to work as
quickly as possible do you do taking
this diet of of like what the hell's
happening in the world first I am I do
find it interesting to know about the
world I don't know that it's useful or
good but it is part of my routine right
now so I do read through a bunch of news
articles and I want to be informed and
um I'm suspicious of it I'm suspicious
of the practice but currently that's
where I am Oh you mean suspicious about
the positive effect yeah of that
practice on your productivity and your
well-being my well-being psychologically
uh and also on your ability to deeply
understand the world because how there's
a bunch of sources of information you're
not really focused on deeply integrating
yeah it's a little bit distracting or
yeah in terms of a perfectly productive
day for how long of a stretch of time
in one session do you try to work and
focus on a thing it's a couple hours is
it one hours and 30 minutes is 10
minutes I can probably go like a small
few hours and then I need some breaks in
between for like food and stuff and uh
yeah but I think like uh it's still
really hard to accumulate hours I was
using a Tracker that told me exactly how
much time I've spent coding any one day
and even on a very productive day I
still spent only like six or eight hours
yeah and it's just because there's so
much padding commute talking to people
food Etc there's like a cost of life
just living and sustaining and
homeostasis and just maintaining
yourself as a human is very high
and and that there seems to be a desire
within the human mind to to uh to
participate in society that creates that
padding yeah because I yeah the most
productive days I've ever had is just
completely from start to finish just
tuning out everything yeah and just
sitting there and then and then you
could do more than six and eight hours
yeah is there some wisdom about what
gives you strength to do like uh tough
days of long Focus
yeah just like whenever I get obsessed
about a problem something just needs to
work some just needs to exist it needs
to exist and you so you're able to deal
with bugs and programming issues and
technical issues and uh design decisions
that turn out to be the wrong ones
you're able to think through all of that
given given that you want that thing to
exist yeah it needs to exist and then I
think to me also a big factor is uh you
know are other humans are going to
appreciate it are they going to like it
that's a big part of my motivation if
I'm helping humans and they seem happy
they say nice things uh they tweet about
it or whatever that gives me pleasure
because I'm doing something useful so
like you do see yourself sharing it with
the world like with this on GitHub is a
blog post or through videos yeah I was
thinking about it like suppose I did all
these things but did not share them I
don't think I would have the same amount
of motivation that I can build up you
enjoy the feeling of other people
uh gaining value and happiness from the
stuff you've created yeah
uh what about diet
is there I saw you playing with
intermittent fast do you fast does that
help with everything
well the things you played what's been
most beneficial to the your ability to
mentally focus on a thing and just meant
the mental productivity and happiness
you still fast yeah it's so fast but I
do intermittent fasting but really what
it means at the end of the day is I skip
breakfast yeah so I do uh 18 6 roughly
by default when I'm in my steady state
if I'm traveling or doing something else
I will break the rules but in my steady
state I do 18 6 so I eat only from 12 to
6. not a hard Rule and I break it often
but that's my default and then um yeah
I've done a bunch of random experiments
for the most part right now where I've
been for the last year and a half I want
to say is I'm um plant-based or planned
forward I heard plant forward it sounds
better exactly I didn't actually know
the differences but it sounds better in
my mind but it just means I prefer
plant-based food and raw or cooked or I
prefer cooked and blunt paste so
plant-based
oh forgive me I don't actually know how
wide the category of planned entails
Wellness just means that you're not uh
and you can flex and uh you just prefer
to eat plants and you know you're not
making you're not trying to influence
other people and if someone is you come
to someone's house party and they serve
you a steak that they're really proud of
you will eat it yes right it's just not
judgment oh that's beautiful I mean
that's
um on the flip side of that but I'm very
sort of flexible have you tried doing
one meal a day I have uh accidentally
not consistently but I've accidentally
had that I don't I don't like it I think
it makes me feel uh not good it's too
it's too much too much of a hit yeah and
uh So currently I have about two meals a
day 12 and six I do that non-stop I'm
doing it now I'm doing one meal a day
okay it's interesting it's an
interesting feeling have you ever fasted
longer than a day yeah I've done a bunch
of water fasts because I was curious
what happens uh anything interesting
yeah I would say so I mean you know
what's interesting is that you're hungry
for two days and then starting day three
or so you're not hungry you know it's
like such a weird feeling because you
haven't eaten in a few days and you're
not hungry isn't that weird it's really
one of the many weird things about human
biology is figure something out it finds
finds another source of energy or
something like that or uh relaxes the
system I don't know how yeah the body is
like you're hungry you're hungry and
then it just gives up it's like okay I
guess we're fasting now there's nothing
and then it's just kind of like focuses
on trying to make you not hungry uh and
you know not feel the the damage of that
and uh trying to give you some space to
figure out the food situation so are you
still to this day most productive uh at
night
I would say I am but it is really hard
to maintain my PhD schedule
um especially when I was say working at
Tesla and so on it's a non-starter uh so
but even now like you know people want
to meet for
various events they Society lives in a
certain period of time and you sort of
have to like work so that's it's hard to
like do a social thing and then after
that return and do work yeah it's just
really hard
uh that's why I try when I do social
things I try not to do too uh too much
drinking so I can return and continue
doing work
um but a Tesla is there is there
conversions in Tesla but any any company
is there a convergence towards the
schedule or is there more
is that how humans behave when they
collaborate I need to learn about this
yeah do they try to keep a consistent
schedule you're all awake at the same
time I mean I do try to create a routine
and I try to create a steady state in
which I'm uh comfortable in uh so I have
a morning routine I have a day routine I
try to keep things to a steady state and
um things are predictable and then you
can sort of just like your body just
sort of like sticks to that and if you
try to stress that a little too much it
will create uh you know when you're
traveling and you're dealing with jet
lag you're not able to really Ascend to
you know where you need to go yeah yeah
that's weird as humans with the habits
and stuff uh what are your thoughts on
work-life balance throughout a human
lifetime
so the testing part was known for sort
of pushing people to their limits
in terms of what they're able to do in
terms of what they're uh trying to do in
terms of how much they work all that
kind of stuff yeah I mean I will say
Tesla gets a little too much uh bad rep
for this because what's happening is
Tesla is a it's a bursty environment so
I would say the Baseline uh my only
point of reference is Google where I've
interned three times and I saw what it's
like inside Google and deepmind
um I would say the Baseline is higher
than that but then there's a punctuated
equilibrium where once in a while
there's a fire and uh someone like
people work really hard and so it's
spiky and bursty and then all the
stories get collected about the bursts
yeah and then it gives the appearance of
like total insanity but actually it's
just a bit more intense environment and
there are fires and Sprints and so I
think uh you know definitely though I I
would say
um it's a more intense environment than
something you would get well you in your
personal forget all of that just in your
own personal life what do you think
about
the happiness of a human being a
brilliant person like yourself
about finding a balance between work and
life or is it such a thing not a good
thought experiment
yeah I think I think balance is good but
I also love to have Sprints that are out
of distribution and that's when I think
I've been pretty uh creative and
um as well Sprints out of distribution
means that most of the time
you you have uh yeah quote-unquote
balance I have balance most of the time
I like being obsessed with something
once in a while once in a while is what
once a week once a month once a year
yeah probably like say once a month or
something yeah and that's when we get a
new GitHub repo come on yeah that's when
you like really care about a problem it
must exist this will be awesome you're
obsessed with it and now you can't just
do it on that day you need to pay the
fixed cost of getting into the groove
and then you need to stay there for a
while and then Society will come and
they will try to mess with you and they
will try to distract you yeah yeah the
worst thing is like a person who's like
I just need five minutes of your time
yeah this is the cost of that is not
five minutes and Society needs to change
how it thinks about just five minutes of
your time right it's never it's never
just one minute it's just 30. it's just
a quick what's the big deal why are you
being so yeah no